[Música]
un río inmerso en el conflicto armado
hasta nueve horas puede durar el
trayecto en Canoa desde su cabecera
hasta la comunidad indígena en vera
dovida de chanu dobida se traduce como
gente del río y es en las Riberas de
estas aguas en el departamento
colombiano del chocó donde la población
sobreviva los confinamientos María
Chamorro recuerda como antes de la
llegada de los paramilitares el eln y el
ejército podían moverse por el
territorio en busca de alimentos
y coge se viola no sé
que estamos pensando
como antes pero antes era no era así
antes que eran no era ese grupo armado
alimentaban bien pero ahora ese grupo
armado bastante que hay un alimento bien
el océano en tierra lo dominan están
llenos de terror todo esto está lleno
con la mina ahora la atención médica de
dos de sus hijas uniéndose así a una
larga lista de familias que desde
primera hora de la mañana se reúne
frente al improvisado consultorio todos
los días vive aceptado todos los días
vive así
uno se cae llorar llora hambre ante las
carencias de las autoridades regionales
y estatales organizaciones como médicos
del mundo brindan a la comunidad
asistencia médica y psicológica con
talleres preventivos y atención a la
salud sexual y reproductiva de las
mujeres un trabajo que realizan de la
mano con el jaivana o médico ancestral
dengue diarreas anemias enfermedades
respiratorias en un solo día los médicos
detectaron cuatro casos de malaria
[Música]
el conflicto no solo golpea los cuerpos
de los indígenas también afecta su buen
vivir su forma de habitar y relacionarse
con su territorio entre susurros hablan
de malos pensamientos como los que tuvo
molanie bakiasa de 12 años sos mi papá
este se siente mal triste en febrero de
2021 su padre falleció debido a una mina
antipersonal su muerte dejó 12 hijos
huérfanos y una finca deshabitada por
temor a represalias de los grupos
armados melva quedó al cuidado de sus
hermanos menores relata como su hermana
intentó suicidarse hace daño en la
tierra en la finca
y perseguí un animal
un diablos
se ahorcó en la taruma amo lani la
encontraron al borde de la muerte
ahorcada con su paruma o falda
tradicional ella dijo que
nolanía ya murió dice así la mamá corrió
aquí venía que pase y ya murió
y
buscó machete
se rajaron
caruma las autoridades sanitarias del
Socorro reportaron 22 suicidios dentro
de los cabildos indígenas en 2021 unas
cifras difusas los confinamientos
desplazamientos y presencia dentro de
las comunidades de los grupos ilegales y
el ejército son algunos factores de esta
epidemia silenciosa tiene que ver mucho
las limitantes del contexto del área
geográfica y del conflicto que está aquí
el poco desarrollo personal que se puede
llegar a tener
la falta de ser escuchados la falta de
los lutos que no se han podido cerrar
porque es una comunidad que tiene
heridas emocionales que aún están
abiertas pese a todo esta comunidad se
resiste a abandonar su territorio 120
miembros hombres y mujeres conforman la
guardia indígena Walter rojas es el
encargado de dialogar con los actores
armados cuando se producen
enfrentamientos o intentan reclutar
forzosamente a los jóvenes de nosotros
tenemos luchando para eso luchando para
eso el territorio nosotros no vamos a
entregar a
a otra persona Mejor dicho al Estado
sino que nosotros mismo vamos a manejar
siempre y cuando vinimos así para eso
los abuelos los abuelos ya lucharon para
el territorio en agosto de este año el
Cabildo de chanum logró 326 votos para
el presidente Gustavo Petro tardaron
cuatro días en Canoa en llevar sus
papeletas a las urnas con el anhelo de
la prometida paz total este noviembre El
Ejecutivo colombiano inició los diálogos
de paz con la guerrilla del ejército de
liberación nacional mientras el
conflicto se perpetúa en los territorios
más aislados el nuevo presidente no lo
puede ser más daño a las comunidades
o no lo puedes tener acá los grupos
Armando donde están los
los embera
Mejor dicho no queremos guerra nosotros
queremos unos procesos de paz el río
bojayá dicen tiene la memoria de las
masacres contra las comunidades afro e
indígenas sucedidas en sus orillas le
cantan para superar el terror las
cantadoras de alabados de pobre Ana
oneida campesina y cantadora Lleva años
componiendo sus letras cantamos al dolor
despedida de los muertos pero también
cantamos a la violencia contando los
atropellos que nos hacen nuestra
comunidad y que los conflicto día a día
sigue más y sigue y seguimos contando
esos cantos rueguen por el río Rubén por
el aire y lleguen hasta
a la casa de nariño donde viven los
presidentes
voces de resistencia desde uno de los
territorios más abandonados de Colombia
con sueño porque ella se aleja más
[Música]